Now,
as we know for our kick and traditional
culture is the symbolic return to chaos
is equivalent to preparing a new
creation.
So the death of your current state of
being can be the preparation for a new
Ba.
Now,
one of the things the cycle analysts
say,
and this is implicit in he adds
discussion of the somatic
transformation,
is if you do this voluntarily,
you have a much better chance of doing
it successfully.
So the rule is while if you go out to
hunt for a dragon and you're in pretty
good shape while you're doing it and
you're all prepared,
then the damn thing might not eat you.
But if you're lying in bed and you know
you're covered with cheesy dust and new,
you're hung over from three days worth
of drinking,
then the dragon will just eat you.
And it's probably a good thing for
everyone that it did.
So.
So the point is,
be prepared and part of the way that
you're prepared is by being awake and
having the,
uh,
the many sources of power that are at
your fingertips that are part of your
biological and cultural inheritance at,
at the ready so that you can respond.
It follows that we may interpret the
psychic chaos of the future showman as a
sign that the profane man is being
dissolved and a new personality being
prepared for birth transformation,
constant theme,
Paradise,
Paradise Lost and redemption.
That's the story of mankind.
We're in a fallen state.
Why is that?
Well,
because things aren't perfect and they
could be better and everyone's
suffering,
so things have fallen apart.
They're always in the state of being
fallen apart.
And what are we trying to do?
What we're trying to put them back
together.
That's the eternal story of mankind
that.